la jolla california i'll be at the la
jolla comedy store august 5th through
the 7th philadelphia pennsylvania i'll
be there august 18th through the 20th
austin texas i will be there september
2nd through the third get your tickets
for those shows and all shows on my
website at ryansickler.com
the honeydew with ryan zickler
[Applause]
welcome back to the honeydew y'all we're
over here doing it in the night pants
studios i'm ryan sickler ryan
sickler.com ryan sickler on all your
social media
thank you for the support if you're new
here if you've been here i love you for
supporting this show and helping out if
you're watching on youtube please hit
that subscribe button it's a real free
easy way to help the show all right if
you got to have more
subscribe to the patreon it's the
honeydew with you all it's five bucks a
month if you sign up for a year you get
over a month free and you're getting the
honeydew a day early ad free at no
additional cost all right i'm
highlighting the low lights with you all
and your stories are absolutely
outrageous we've released 10 episodes on
the youtube channel one had to be taken
down
and um you can go check those out to get
a taste of what the patreon is like it's
a weekly show and if you or someone you
know has that story that has to be heard
please submit it to honeydewpodcast
gmail.com
uh tour dates actually in town this week
if you live in la i'm doing a ryan
sickler and friend show at the comedy
store um it's thursday night the lineup
is sick
go check it out if you're in town um but
uh la jolla i'll be there this weekend
august 5th through the 7th philadelphia
august 18th through the 20th in austin
september 2nd and the 3rd labor day
weekend get your tickets for those shows
and all shows at ryanstickler.com now
that's the biz you guys know we do over
here we highlight the low lights i
always say these are the stories behind
the storytellers and i am very excited
to have this guest on today first time
here on the honeydew ladies and
gentlemen please welcome adam carolla
welcome to the honeydew adam corolla
thanks for having me thank you for being
here dude this is uh this is a long
overdue i've been wanting to have you on
here i uh i agree this is something i
dreamt of i think of my sophomore year
in high school
so did it look like a lot
uh yeah the motif was pretty pretty
close you didn't have a beard back then
no but and and i think we both put on a
couple pounds but that this is something
i've had in my mind for a long time so
thanks for having me you're welcome i'm
glad to make the vision you know
complete yeah uh before we get into what
you want to talk about please plug
promote everything anything you'd like
uh i got a book that's just out uh
called everything reminds me of
something and you can get it wherever
you find books it's another comedy book
i write yeah it's i think i'm on my
sixth uh comedy book are you really six
yeah it's crazy blink your eyes and
you've done six comedy books and then
you can go to adamkroller.com for dates
or listen to the podcast or whatever you
like
so you are obviously you go back to the
original days of this they you're also
one of the pod fathers they say
um
i mean i grew up listening to you on
love line i say grow up we're not that
i mean how old are you now
i just turned 58. um damn dude you look
great out there you're two years from
sixth you're brad pitt's age bro you
look [ __ ] great
i like that thing where he can't
remember people's faces
i'd like to invent some disease for me
to get me out of trouble i'm sorry i'm
sorry ladies i can't eat [ __ ] i have a
note
no my dr drew is
drafted something here so i don't
remember your face
and then the other affliction i have is
i can't eat [ __ ] but those are my only
two
i'm going to beyond impressed you look
fantastic oh oh and i can't sit close to
people when i eat indoors who talk too
loud
in a dining situation so those are my
three kind of afflictions but thank you
all right
um
i want to go back to times when you
weren't successful when you were at your
lowest you said feel free to ask you so
um
talk to me about some of the times
you've struggled in life and what you
went through
um i started off in a very weird
family that you know
by all
circumstances
seems very different than almost anybody
else's family because i think most
people think in terms of poverty and
they think in terms of abuse there's
physical sexual substance you know all
kinds of verbal abuse my family is very
unique in their approach to abuse
which was
they were poor
and my mom was like
welfare and food stamps and stuff and we
were we're poor we weren't like
impoverished we were just
there was no money but we didn't you
know i'd have to eat out of dumpsters
but
my family treated their kids as if they
weren't their own you know like this
weird crazy hands-off
felt like i didn't have parents like
when i was when i was nine
and they weren't you know beating me or
telling me i'm stupid or ugly it just it
was like i didn't it's like they didn't
know who i was i didn't know who they
were
it was it became like
really clear that they weren't going to
take care of me or do anything for me
like
it was like oh you're on your own you
know when when i was when my sister was
14 she ran away
and
and for good and oh really
pretty much pretty much and the thing
that's funny is if you know when you
talk to dr drew
he'll go like a a young girl
only runs away
because she's being sexually abused or
physically abused and i'm like
she wasn't being abused physically or
sexually it was such a vacuum
of attention
and nurturing there was it was there was
nothing there she literally just left
like like a stray cat and you stopped
putting out saucers of milk and
eventually they just
like walked to the other house tell me
about your mom and dad then because
they're both the same way because
usually at least have one that's in
there that's like trying to nurture or
do something
it is a weird it's a weird combo and
were they together the whole time too no
no they're both
generally kind of depressed
really low-key kind of passionless
people you know my mom is probably
you know pretty clinically depressed
like you know she had a hard
life she was
raised
you know she went to child protective
services when she was a kid and she was
like raised by the grandparents and
didn't know the grandparents
weren't her biological parents because
she was so young and
you know oh your mom grew up thinking
her grandparents were her parents at
first yeah oh wow yeah and and
you know the
my grandmother's her mom's brother
killed himself like like the kind of
here's the kind of i'll tell you like
who my family is like my
my grandmother's brother robert puts a
rifle in his mouth and blows his brains
out right when he's you know in his 30s
and my grandmother hated him
so she was kind of like good and then
and then i was like but here's how they
are here's how my family is here's where
my grandmother is and my whole family is
this way like
he killed himself in a little small
little you know 900 square foot ranch
house in you know north hollywood in
1947 or something
and i said to my i said to my
grandmother once i was like he killed
himself in the house and she's like yeah
and then he killed himself and then me
and
your grandfather we moved in you know
and i said
and uh
he killed himself like in the house yeah
it was in the room and we made that room
uh your grandfather's office or
something i said you didn't have
feelings about that and she's like what
are you talking about and i said well
your brother he killed himself in the
house the house is 900 square feet
seemed
weird she's like why
and i said
you know like realtors have a law that
if somebody kills themselves in the
house like within three years or five
years they have to reveal it she's like
get the [ __ ] out of here
and i was like
grandma people have feelings about these
things she's like why why
so that's like who she is i mean 900
square feet the blood splatter could be
on the other side of the wall over here
right yeah and
she's so like that's how she was
and my mom
so let me ask i don't mean interrupt but
no no
i mean is the work
i don't want to say cold but were they
cold was it or just distant or not
disconnected
yeah disconnected not cold like for the
sake of being cold right just like just
it's
basically it's like this
everyone in my family is like listen
uh it'd be like if i said to my kids
look i'm totally [ __ ] up i got my own
problems and i'm a [ __ ] full-time job
just i'm i'm gonna go in the bedroom and
shut the door because i got my own [ __ ]
going on so you know whatever you need
for food or bicycles or tough skins or
whatever just [ __ ] you're on your own
it's a sinking ship and it's every man
for themselves and you're growing up in
the valley right yeah
so is it just you and your sister the
only siblings so what what age do you
realize that this is different because
you know we've talked about
when you grow up in something it's
normal until you start going to sleep at
a friend's house and that's when i was
like oh you guys get hugs yeah yeah oh
what kind of cereal do you guys have
yeah things like that when do you
realize that this dynamic is different
and not you know normal
you know i
it was more i i wasn't really doing a
dynamic
psycho
analyzation of it i was like
my
friends have
air conditioning and wall-to-wall carpet
and their moms make pork chops and
meatloaf and so i'm going there and then
i'm going to hang out
and i'm going to sleep over because i
got air conditioning and then there's
stuff to eat and they have a pantry with
you know space sticks in it and cupcakes
and [ __ ] and i'm like i'm just gonna and
there's none of that at my house and you
know my
the group the bar was pretty low i you
know it's from north hollywood this is
the 70s early 80s i'm hanging around
with just dudes who live you know
parents live in apartments and you know
some miniature houses and
you know there's a fair bit of
dysfunction and alcoholism and divorce
and you know they have their own
problems they don't have my unique
problems which is sort of parents that
don't know they have kids they have more
their own dynamic going on but either
way
i just lived in everyone else's house
eight i certainly ate 700 meals at other
people's houses
and then are you close with your sister
kind of yes and no like she
it was clear that at my house it was
every man for themselves so
my sister did what she had to do and i
did what i had to do and she had her
friends and she went and hung out at
their house and i had my friends and i
went hung out at their house and so we
never really had
we didn't you know i guess there's two
relationships you can have you can have
a
you know a functional family where
siblings are closed and then you can
have this horrible abusive family where
the siblings are taking care of each
other
we had a third option which is you go
north i'll go south and i'll see you
when we're in our 30s
oh
did that happen did you reconnect and
yeah like you know late so we didn't
really have a base cause we everyone was
just running their own direction trying
to get fed and
ha you know have some semblance of a
childhood and so we never had any
any
real relationship i also realized that
i resented her
to some degree because there was a
character in this whole crazy plot which
was my
jewish
step-grandfather who's this uh hungarian
named lazlo gorag
and he was sort of sane
and he would look at my family go what
you have to make dinner you know what i
mean like you gotta give someone a
sweater and a hug like he was a normal
he was an old-school jew from
from budapest who fled you know when the
nazis started to roll in
and he was kind of normal
and
he he was probably quietly disgusted at
sort of my mom and my dad and the way
they sort of conducted you know your kid
you know when they go to school you got
to pack them a lunch or you have to give
them a dollar you can't just send them
with no money and no lunch to you know
scrounge
um
so when my
sister ran away
he as the jewish grandfather was very
distraught you know very upset my my mom
and my dad didn't
it was kind of bullet dodge for them
like i've got one less mouth not to feed
you know like one one less half really
they weren't torn they weren't
devastated they weren't like where's our
daughter you know you're they would they
would if you
talked to them they would say oh we were
very upset or something but they did not
show
signs of it and they didn't
you know put out a dragnet or you know
wasn't like where's dad he's driving up
and down van nuys boulevard it's
midnight he's looking for you know it
wasn't it wasn't you know george c scott
and hardcore you know he wasn't
out beating the bushes you know it's
like hang out call her friend jenny
she's not there well we're out ideas and
my grandfather was the one who was like
wringing his hands and very upset you
know this is your mom's dad or your dad
this is a step grandfather but this is
this is my mom's dad who is the step dad
who she never knew the real dad so then
tell me about your mom and dad their
relationship did they treat each other
the same way they treated the kid like
were they also hey every person for
themselves
my dad is
you know grew up in south philly just
just poor and depressed and italian
family and
just
totally
not an effective person just couldn't
turn a wrench couldn't make a buck you
know just just just weird
it it's kind of a with a little bit of a
mentality which is weird it's maybe it
was kind of a south philly thing like
his dad
played a little trumpet back when they
had big bands and you know it was like a
blue collar job playing a trumpet you
know what i mean
but he kind of hung out you know it was
a kind of knock around kind of you know
these guys on a tuesday just playing
like pinocchio the cafe all day you know
like not not really the gig would be
friday night or something like that and
my dad and his kind of his cousin moved
out here
um vince
they kind of had that same mentality
like they didn't they weren't like
career oriented they didn't they didn't
seem to be on a path they were just kind
of knock around kind of hang around
guys and so my dad was like a decent
enough guy but he wasn't going to do
anything for you he didn't have any
money he wasn't ambitious he was just
kind of
worked a little as like a substitute
school teacher
drove an old vw bug you know just kind
of got by didn't
didn't like cooking or camping or it
says everything you just got by you know
you just the whole family the whole plan
was
just live
you don't
you know set your sights to the stars or
anything i'm just sort of hang out get
by
and they weren't really good times
people like they wouldn't
they didn't drink they didn't have a
team they liked they didn't have a band
they followed or like they didn't go to
concerts or ball games or
or i didn't have a favorite steak joint
or anything my my dad would just kind of
sit around
his idea of dinner was like a bowl of
cottage cheese with some raisins
like he didn't even eat he didn't eat
steak
and he likes steak he just you know
costs money we're going to go without
money
he just kind of sat around it was very
weird you know you don't meet too many
guys like him and not affectionate with
each other your mom and dad especially
in front of you guys no no they were
huge they were both really kind of just
awkward and damaged and not affectionate
and you know no birthdays or
anniversaries or greeting cards or
gifts or birthdays none of that what do
you remember about the holidays
uh we
my grandmother
had a
a rubber tree a potted rubber tree plant
inside her living room and she would
decorate it with tinsel which looked
weird
and then my mom one year we just cut a
branch off this old
crappy pine tree we had in our front
yard and just kind of leaned it like
against the wall it was just flat and
just kind of decorated the branch it was
really like charlie brown [ __ ] anything
like that
maybe
my we'd go to my grandparents house on
new on christmas eve and open gifts
small gifts and that was about it no we
didn't do christmas on christmas day we
didn't do stockings and stuff way back
in the day
like five or six there was there was a
window
of about three years where my parents
were sort of married and they were
trying to
keep up with the joneses a little bit
appearances wise like my mom
would put makeup on and she wasn't fat
and she she got her hair done or
something she she put together like
three years
you know in the late 60s where where
there was a kind of a normal we're
trying to be normal you know and then at
some point
we got to the early 70s and depression
kicked in and divorce and separation and
my mom just [ __ ] let it she's you
know not shaving my armpits anymore not
putting makeup on not dying my hair i'm
just going to walk around get welfare
checks just kind of hang out
so you know financially
financially just just as a
so you you have like a yardstick to
measure where my family was financially
and
because you know it's kind of in vogue
now where everyone is like uh
these claims of poverty some are
nobility you know it's like
joe biden is like we used to sit around
the kitchen table when gas would go up
from 29 cents to 30 cents so my dad
would have a conversation it's like
when you got married you got a brand new
corvette from your dad yeah it's like
these these people tell these stories
they go oh yeah my family times were
tough anyway my first year abroad in
europe yeah my
freshman year in college it's like
[ __ ] europe yeah well we didn't have
a lot of money it's like listen i grew
up with people didn't have a lot of
money you went from high school to a
construction site you did labor that was
it there was no
year abroad or my second year at
stanford there was
didn't none of that that didn't exist
like this is real
poor people [ __ ] and
when my parents
broke up
when i was about eight years old
first off
they never got divorced they just broke
up and the reason they never got
divorced is because they didn't own
anything between the two of them they
lived in my grandmother's second junker
house my dad had a vw bug
and there was no they didn't have
furniture like it was literally like why
file for 33 dollars
when we don't have anything there's no
reason to even put memorialize anything
on paper there's nothing to discuss it's
just like two homeless people walking
away from each other you know yeah
look we only know like whose shopping
cart is this so who do you live
primarily with when that happens then
well so here's how busted my dad was
he is moving out he's got he can't
afford a one-bedroom apartment in north
hollywood in 1972
four
and what do you think it costs back then
it's probably oh yeah 129 a month or
something
he he goes
to
my mom's parents house
who
now so he's going to the house
of
the woman he's leaving's parents
they have a one bedroom house in north
hollywood one bathroom that's off of
their bedroom and he sleeps in an
oversized hall closet
this man at this point is like 41 years
old
he's in his [ __ ] early 40s
and he breaks up with his wife and he
with two kids and he goes to the [ __ ]
grandparent's house and sleeps in a
closet because he can't
financially swing
an apartment at this point that's that's
where he was financially
and your mom is able to keep you guys at
least in this house and keep our
apartment and keep you afloat
my mom's in a house but it's her mom's
second rental house that she bought a
house to rent out a junker house in
north hollywood
but now her daughter's become unable to
take care of herself so she lets the
daughter live in the junker house for
free essentially because she can't take
care of herself so we lived
in the junker house for free
and then at some point my dad got an
apartment
and then we kind of split our time
in between the apartment and the the
house what was he doing to get money at
that point that he finally got an
apartment
he worked as a
like a substitute school teacher like
kind of a special needs-y kind of school
teacher and then at some point
worked for a place called five acres
which is
uh
what is
what we used to call an orphanage
essentially and he was a teacher
at the orphanage
which is still there two orphans at
how about you home some [ __ ] food
home from the orphanage dad
would you bring a can of milk
seriously yeah summer is full of
official events like weddings
graduations and annual fourth of july
barbecues but everyone knows the best
parts of summer are the unofficial ones
this summer coors light is the official
beer of everything
unofficial celebrating those moments
that truly make summer chill the first
day of summer is officially june 21st
unofficially it's whenever it's warm
enough to enjoy a beer on the patio the
weekend is officially saturday and
sunday unofficially it's friday
afternoon too all right you guys know
i'm a coors light drinker my buddy eric
was just here
and i promise you there's a sizable dent
in the southern california coors light
stock
there is only one beer out there that's
literally made to chill and that is
coors lake the mountains on the bottles
and cans even turn blue when your beer
is cold
and when you need to hit reset just open
a coors light it's cold lager cold
filtered and cold packaged it's
literally made to chill summer chill
starts with coors light make the most of
your summer with a chance to win
exclusive chill merch fun local
experiences even a trip to new york
chicago or los angeles enter to win at
coorslight.com
honeydew no purchase necessary
sweepstakes ends august 15 2022 game
ends september 6
2022. 50 us dc 21 plus only voiware
prohibited for rules visit
coorslightsummer.com
coors brewing company golden colorado
celebrate responsibly what would you do
if you didn't have high interest loans
or credit card debt would you move to a
new city or start a family through
upstart you can pay off your existing
debt quickly with a personal loan so you
can tackle your next big financial goal
whether it's paying off credit cards
consolidating high interest debt or
funding personal expenses over a million
people have used upstart to get one
fixed monthly payment with a clear
payoff date upstart knows you're more
than just your credit score so rather
than looking at your credit score alone
upstart's model considers other factors
like your income employment and other
information provided in your loan
application to find you a smarter rate
for your loan you can check your rate
without impacting your credit score in
just five minutes for loans between one
thousand to fifty thousand dollars you
can even receive funds as fast as one
business day after accepting your loan
find out how upstart can lower your
monthly payments today when you go to
upstart.com honeydew that's upstart.com
honeydew don't forget to use my url to
let them know i sent you loan amounts
will be determined based on your credit
income and certain other information
provided in your loan application go to
upstart.com slash honeydew you are a
unique mashup of all your favorite
things and there's a multitude of ways
to express yourself celebrate all that
you are and explore who you can be with
customizable prescription glasses from
pear eyewear i've gotten the uh black
regular frames all right
i like that like you know
that classic style classic style and uh
and then you've got these colors you can
snap on and stuff and i keep saying it
like you really would think ah you're
gonna be able to see that it's i'm
telling you no it looks like it's all
part of the glasses they're so good
um i like them a lot you don't even need
to buy that many you get the one then
you just pop pop pop you know what i'm
talking about get started by choosing
your base frame with options from the
square to the cat eye that's what i'm
talking about y'all every frame comes in
six different colorways including
classic black to the remix blue tortoise
then pick your top frames and build a
collection to match your personality for
every pair purchased pair provides
glasses and vision care for children
around the world which is awesome get
glasses as unique as you are one pair
infinite style starting at just sixty
dollars go to pairwear.com
honeydew for 15 off your first purchase
that's 15 off at p-a-i-r-i-where
dot com slash honeydew now let's get
back to the do all right so if these are
your parents
who do you find
as an adult influencer like do you have
a coach a teacher is there someone that
that you're like this person's normal
they sort of take you under their wing a
little bit or at least give you some
guidance like who is that for you
growing up i
i i gravitate towards sports very
immediately
i was a weird kind of gifted kid
i was gifted athletically i wasn't
gifted
in terms of school
as a student at all but
but i was weirdly kind of gifted as a
kid and i say gifted and that i could
just do stuff other kids couldn't do
kind of physically when i was young you
know i was just
i had this weird sense of balance i
could balance i could ride a unicycle i
could do anything that had to do with
balance and i had such a weird balance
that
i think it kind of translated into
i could wrestle any kid to strom on the
ground in a second it wasn't like big
and muscular or anything i said this
weird balance or somehow thing and i
just throw everyone around and i was
just sort of better than than everyone
physically so i i went to
something i could do
which is play football so i started
playing like pee-wee football when i was
like
seven or eight
and i i like i i don't know if i liked
it but i guess i craved the discipline
my house was kind of a free-for-all just
go wherever you want do whatever you
want go just look
you know we had a tacit agreement which
is you can do whatever you want just
don't ask us for [ __ ] you know what i
mean and it was kind of understood too
like
well if you're not cooking or giving me
money then why are you setting a curfew
you're making rules but you're not
supplying anything so if you're not
going to supply anything then no rules
and
that was kind of their agreement like it
wasn't spoken but it was like yeah we're
not in charge of you and you do what you
want you know what i mean
and
and football was very disciplined and
very rigid and guy you know
old dads yelling you know actually we
did wind sprints and push-ups and just
kicking the [ __ ] out of you you know
especially
back in the 70s when they could really
kick the [ __ ] out of you you know they
would give you water they'd call you a
candy ass they'd
put you down in your three-point stance
come around kick your foot kick your
hand out from under you and make fall in
the face and start yelling at you i mean
they
whatever
would be grounds for abuse
and they'd be brought up on charges now
they could do back then and i was down
with all of it i mean it it hurt it was
tough i i was thirsty it was hot but but
i i craved it you know so i kept going
back
and so i i got some
base of of discipline and achievement
through
through sports
okay
was there any person in that was
overly influential or someone that
really stuck out that you remember that
you were like man i'm glad that person
was around
yeah i had you know mr gallagher and mr
fitzgerald and you know these kinds of
people in my
uh east valley trojan days and then i
went to the sun valley falcons and mr
burr was the coach and mr whitman and
these these guys
you know first off i have no idea what
their first name was right
isn't that funny we're on a full last
name basis with coach burr and coach
whitman coach gallagher
actually gallagher's first name was duke
gallagher and i only remember that
because he had such a great name
gallagher yeah and
he uh and and so these people were like
normal and they had families and i ended
up hanging out with a lot of the the
boys and
i only knew the boy not only but i
mostly knew the boys last name too it
was like corolla and fitzgerald and
stuff just like that's who you were you
know that's how we did it that was
sports you know and i kind of i kind of
learned that and and i got some
sense of some sense of self-esteem or
accomplishment or something because i
had this sort of non-existent
self-esteem i
you know my parents didn't say you're
dumb or you're ugly or stupid you know
it was just kind of you didn't
exist to them so this sort of weird
non-existent self-esteem i didn't really
exist would they come to games would
they see you in this element
not really that the a little bit my mom
wouldn't
my dad
on occasion would come but he'd he'd do
this weird thing that was kind of a
strange element which is he wouldn't sit
up in the bleachers if he did come
he'd sit out on the field in a little
lawn folding chair and then he'd bring a
book
and he'd put himself like right where
you could see him you know away from
everybody and every time i looked at him
he'd just have his face buried in his
book which is like a weird
message
being sent and i never really thought
that much about but he was always kind
of
had his face in his book i mean if he
won went they weren't they didn't like
it
really they didn't get it my dad wasn't
a sports guy yeah you said they're not a
target guy
no
all right so where do you get this then
where do you because obviously you're a
[ __ ] hustler where do you get
that what where does that get instilled
in you because you
are clearly opposite of what is
professionally especially of your father
and your mom so where do you get that
i i i didn't really get it i i it just
started to kind of
creep in like i was like
i was a bad student i was a good athlete
i wasn't
going anywhere i had
some scholarship offers from
[Music]
you know medium size
smaller you know cal poly pomona cal
poly san luis obispo
uc davis marshall
willamette university lewis and clark
like these little so i didn't know where
they were
um
when i got out of high school i was in
high school i i i didn't take the sats i
didn't take algebra like i didn't know
what to do with the paperwork i i didn't
have any guidance and i couldn't do
anything and so um
i just knew i was gonna have to work
real hard that that's all that was my
only thought that's you're gonna have to
bust your ass
and i didn't have an intellectual
capacity to to fill out
uh
an application and get a job inside with
some air conditioning or whatever it was
all physical for me like you're gonna
get a job where you move boxes you know
you move stuff you dig ditches you work
you know what i mean like to me
i didn't know there's any other kind of
work other than work right you know you
you moved [ __ ] that's how you got work
the work to me was there's a truck it's
full of stuff go get it out of that
truck and go put it in that warehouse
and that that was my definition of work
you know
and i mean i understood there were
doctors and lawyers and stuff but that
that wasn't going to be me i couldn't i
could barely spell my name so i was like
i'm going to work and so i i just went
to work so i i
you know walked onto a construction site
and they handed me a shovel and i
started
digging footings you know in silver lake
and i remember just kind of going
you
you got to hang on to this job with both
hands you can't risk getting fired for
being lazy or something so i i just
worked really hard and so i always kind
of understood the work part of life
because that's all i knew that's all i
came from
you know later on i started thinking
about working a little smarter
you know
taking
this
ethic and maybe applying it to not just
getting seven bucks an hour i see all
the time take that blue collar work
ethic into the white collar world
right yes right
and that's that's what i started to
arrive at
at a certain point but it was very
incremental
i didn't read a tony robbins book i
didn't attend a seminar
i i didn't watch a financial report or
something i i really never it was just
very slow and incremental and and the
first
kind of glimpses i started to have is
when i was like 22
like 22 21 22 just kind of live in an
apartment one bedroom with two roommates
you know like three dudes in a one
bedroom like bunk beds you know north
hollywood no air conditioning you know
driving a
beat up mini truck and
you know probably making nine bucks an
hour back then and
you know no auto insurance no no dental
no medical and this kind of and also
construction was very like
day labory stuff like if it rained you
didn't work and you didn't get paid and
i didn't have a credit card there was
there was nothing it was just like kind
of getting paid nine bucks an hour and
living you know
and
i i just remember being like 22 kind of
like sitting in my apartment going
really this is it this is it you're just
gonna
you're gonna work your way up to a
bigger truck and you're gonna work your
way up to 16 bucks an hour one day or
something and some more tools or
whatever but
just getting up at six every morning and
driving to canoga park and working with
a bunch of meat heads on a job site like
is that is that where this is that what
this is
and i i and i just remember thinking i i
i would have these little glimpses
because when you get caught up
in the hourly world
you know you make seven bucks an hour
and my i was riding my motorcycle to
work you know and and my boss was like
you get a pickup truck i'll give you
another buck an hour
a buck an hour and i was like i'm gonna
find me a pickup truck
mazda
mini truck from the 70s you know 900
bucks you know piece of junk you know
bought a junker pickup truck got to
eight bucks an hour you know and then at
some point you get to nine bucks an hour
and you
see some guy roll onto the side he's
making 15 an hour here and you're like
holy [ __ ] look at that guy man
and i i did have an insight when i was
like 22 i was like
even if you got
50 bucks an hour and that seemed you
know ungodly and un
obtainable but
even if you get 50 bucks an hour
but you're still doing something you
don't want to do by the hour
essentially getting paid to be miserable
because that's what construction was
just go somewhere you don't want to go
work out in the sun all day and just
stare at the clock just waiting for
lunch time you know always you're always
waiting waiting for lunch time waiting
for the whistle to blow you know i was
like even if you got 50 bucks an hour
and that was an extreme example for me
you still wouldn't have a good life
you'd just be being paid to be miserable
and a better wage and you're being paid
now to be miserable and so i was like
what about doing something
that you would enjoy
or that was fulfilling or interesting
and working with people that are
interesting you know
that was that shift all right so are
your parents still alive
um my mom passed recently my dad's still
alive that's all right and you have kids
right mm-hmm
so
how do your kids
they're 16 year old boy girl twins okay
great
um you've told me what kind of parents
they were did they change as
grandparents were they a little better
were they more attentive in their older
years what what were they like as
grandparents
um
no i mean they just they kept it who
they were
yeah
yeah my uh you know honestly
the relationship they had
my mom passed away like
six seven weeks ago oh man i'm sorry
that's all right we didn't
didn't have a relationship
um or much of a relationship i haven't
told my kids
get the [ __ ] almost two months ago yeah
and you haven't told the kids they don't
it's neither here nor there to them
they'll just be all into
i just wait for them to ask
if they don't have they don't have a
relate they didn't have how'd your mom
die just old age how old
she was 89.
how do you feel about that
this is all new for you haven't even
told your kids if you've not told your
kids because you're still processing
this or you're just now i'm just lazy
lazy to tell somebody
i'm not a big talker
i kind of keep to myself you know i keep
my head down dude are you ah man that is
complicated right there
i it's do you talk to your dad about
your mom dying yeah my dad was kind of
into it not into it a positive way but
he he was like you gotta go tell her you
love her and i was like i don't think
she can hear me dan he's like say it
anyway he got he got very i think a lot
of it was projection on his point guilt
his thing he's like 90 91 but
no you know the thing about
not really having much of a relationship
with somebody
i think people think
that
oh
but but come on it's your mom like like
they have a oh but come on kind of
feeling but
i'm here to say not really having a
relationship with someone is not really
having a relationship with someone it
doesn't the mom it's like saying
your neighbor it's like you're going i
don't have a relationship with my
neighbor
and then someone going but but what
about i understand not having a
relationship with someone who lives 10
houses down but not your neighbor and
you go
i don't have a relationship with my dad
ever they go i understand someone 20
houses down it's like
but they're so close it's like yeah i
know but if you don't have a
relationship you don't really have a
relationship i will co-sign on that i
reconnected with my mother just a few
years ago after
25 years and i can tell you
that if we had not reconnected
i would agree with you it was it was
just this other person that i haven't
that's tossed me aside and hadn't wanted
to talk to me in 30 [ __ ] years you're
right you don't have
i know people want to say that now deep
down the like and the to me my always my
answer was always the deeper you go the
less that's there right you know what i
mean right i think you can understand
that like you
if you want to get something it's going
to be up here the deeper you go there's
nothing there there are no roots
no i and that's what people think
you're going back and and drawing on
some history
but if there's no history then what
where's your base right where's the
foundation what are you going back to
you know all right so then as a father
do you how do you decide to break this
cycle are you as active in your kids are
you doing are you over compensating are
you over correcting or are you just
being a good dad
i you know as a dad i'm not
i'm not really full of
dad
instinct which which i'm aware of you
know coming from where i come from
so you know my first impulse was
my first impulse was sort of
i had a few impulses one my one impulse
was
you got to wait to have kids because you
don't have any money and you're screwed
up and your family screwed up and you
must delay this this process until you
can
get a base get a foundation
financially
i was like i i i grew up in this
world where it's like
financial i remember my mom had an old
vw station wagon you know everything was
an old vw everything was broken down all
the time and i remember
at some point i wanted to go i lived in
north hollywood i had a close friend who
lived in van nuys you know and as the
crow flies probably
four and a half miles away you know and
my mom you know it's like giving me a
ride to van nuys was always like oh god
no you know you gotta you gotta give me
three weeks notice you know whatever
and
i just remember this i remember at some
point
kind of
being wising up like like and i was
always kind of good at math which is
weird so i was like
it was gas gas is so expensive gas gas
was during the 70s gas crunch you know
it's gas gas guys and i was like
your vw
wagon gets like 25 30 miles to the
gallon gas is
72 cents a gallon
teddy's house is five miles from here
this is gonna cost you
23 cents
23 and she just looked at me and she
went
every time you start the car it costs
money
every time
the tires the belts
the oil the wear and the tear and i was
like
jesus [ __ ] christ we're arguing over
34 cents i can't just get a ride to
[ __ ] van eyes
like okay i'll walk to van nuys but i
mean it's like i i was like i don't want
to do that [ __ ] with my kids
talking to him about every time you
start the car it costs you know i i so i
was like i want to get my career i'm
going to be established i'm going to
make money i want to like take care of
them
what i do is i i'm a very
i'm i
i very much try to lead by example like
i'm like
i work hard you must work hard i shall
show you how i work hard and like how i
treat people and how i conduct and
comport myself so my first thought was
just like i'm not going to sit around
tell them what to do
the whole time you know i'm not going to
be
smoking a cigarette through a donut and
talk to him about health you know i'm
going to i'm gonna take care of myself
and they can watch and i'll have little
conversations with them but
i'm gonna just go by example and so that
that's kind of
a lot of parenting for me is just by
here's how you conduct yourself watch
watch me
and then the other part is i will
have passions and loves and things that
i want to do and
my parents were
full-blown bummers the whole time i was
a kid i'm not gonna bum my kids out like
i'm not gonna tell them how bad it is or
how whatever
and i'm not gonna use my childhood as an
excuse not to hug them or talk to them
or tell them i love them or whatever it
is
and so and i will overcompensate big
kiss on the lips before you go to bed at
night love you hug you know i'm i'm it's
easy it's free
i also one of my main things and i and
it is from my family being so depressed
and downtrodden and stuff like that is
you know let's have a dance party let's
[ __ ] around let's be silly let's be
goofy let's be fun and and then i'll
tell them
all the time like in this awesome
who would you rather have as a dad you
know this is great oh i'm so glad you
guys are here
let's have a good time you know what i
mean like all the stuff i never heard
cause people are always like oh you know
you're poor you're poor you're poor yeah
you're poor that means you can't go to
disneyland that doesn't mean you can't
love someone or have a dance party or be
silly or crack a joke or throw a ball in
the front yard that's that shit's all
free all the stuff the kid wants is free
my core memories are all that [ __ ] it
was never we didn't go i mean we went to
disney world like once we didn't go on
trips or our vacation i'm from maryland
our vacation was you go to ocean city
for a few days there's no
europe there's no [ __ ] even going to
california none of that [ __ ] we never
went anywhere but the memories i have
that stand out were
fishing crabbing
fun sports hanging out
is there any moment that ever that does
if there was one that stands out with
your parents from growing up where
you're like holy [ __ ] this is
a we're proud of you graduation anything
is there anything where they were where
you were like holy [ __ ] this is not
normal for them that really stands out
no my my family had a weird kind of
aversion to their
kids
in a sort of weird way i guess i can
i'll give you a couple examples and then
you
you tell me how one would process it
my mom was more screwed up than my dad
and my mom was sort of
kind of aggressive sometimes negatively
her
her mom
was very aggressive negatively because
she would say very negative things
my mom would just sort of act it but not
really say it so much and my dad would
just be like huh what you know what i
mean like you could
you know you could say to my my dad
could say what's up and then you'd go my
book's coming out tuesday and he'd go
okay there you go
but he'd never go like what's it about
yeah very good word or something like
that he would never get the book or
never asked to see it or or
even it at
now even through your years he's an avid
reader
you can go she read at the football
games that's right
you can go check his
go check his bookshelf my book does not
on there not any of them
no it's just it's he but he's kind of
passive
about it my mom
was a little more like i'll give you
two mom's stories about where she was at
uh later on in life
i was uh sort of became successful in
show business
and it was like my grandmother's 85th
birthday or something we went to a thai
food restaurant or something it was my
mom and the grandma and
oh god i got a good grandma story too
all right so i'll tell you who they are
like how they roll
so i was my grandma my mom my stepdad
and my sister and me or whatever just
six eight six people sitting around and
we're just kind of talking about nothing
and my
at the time
i was on
love line on mtv every night so i had a
nightly one-hour show on mtv and then i
had a
weekly
show on uh on comedy central so the man
show was on and and
and love line we're both on
cable tv
now
this is now we're into the you know it's
2000 2001 or something and my mom
announces to the table i you know i she
says i got a flyer
and it was a flyer for uh to get cable
you know 14.99 a month whatever and they
keep dropping these things off because
she's the last
adult in in north hollywood that does
without a cable right they're they're
flummoxed you know they're probably
they're having vigils on their front
lawn you know and
and so she looks around at the table and
she goes
can anyone give me one good reason why i
should get cable
now i had two her son had two shows on
cable but
and the table couldn't
summon an answer as well so that's kind
of
who my mom is right and then later on
this is a very mom move to or my mom
later on she she rolls in
she coming over on a sunday to eat
scones
and she comes into my house and she goes
uh she has a videotape with her and
she's not the kind of person that wants
you to see this episode of seinfeld or
we never talk comedy or show business
she doesn't know
a [ __ ] thing she doesn't have cable
she just knows i go somewhere at night
and do a show or something now
my family sort of knows well now he
doesn't drive a truck he drives a bmw
but that's about all they can
figure cause no one has
cable right
they don't know what that you know my
dad would be like are you doing the uh
puppet uh the cra the uh
what was that
on the comedy that show no the comedy
station what is that are you still like
literally you could be like season four
of cranky anchors in my dad doesn't know
the name of the show or like where it is
you know and even my sister would be
like what number is the comedy puppet
station
is that what number is that how many
puppets
what a way to tell someone
i don't know what number it is on your
you live in topanga yeah i i don't know
if it's 132 or 344 like but you can
google it or
figure it out that's who my family is
like huh what you know and part of it is
like
we're sending a message and the other
part is just oh what
so my mom
she comes and she's got a vhs tape
now
she goes
first things first this is like
2007. she goes
have you heard of this guy
this comedian
john stewart
like okay i'm on the same network as jon
stewart you know i've been a guest on
he's a friend you know i've had dinner
with john's turn i'm like we have the
same age
james dixon
it goes all the way to jon stewart right
so i go she goes have you heard of this
guy jon stewart now part of it is like
she has no
intellectual understanding of
first off you've heard of jon stewart
and you collect welfare so i'm a
comedian who's on the same network he's
on so
she probably doesn't know him on
you know anyway so it's like have you
heard of jon stewart so i'm
you know i'm doing what i always do with
her like oh yeah it sounds familiar
sounds familiar she's waving the tape
around he is funny funny i saw him on
oprah this is what i got i got him on
oprah i've never seen something so funny
and i'm thinking to myself
she never brought a tape in she never
talked about a comedian she has no
thoughts about comedy but all of a
sudden she marches in she's waving this
tape around and she's like we're gonna
we're gonna eat some scones and then
we're gonna we're gonna watch this you
know
and i'm like okay all right
and so
she keeps talking about jon stewart and
at some point my wife at the time
chimes in she can't take it anymore she
does
she goes
she goes you know
they have the same agent adam and john
are friends and they're on the same
network together
and my mom pauses
and she like looks at the tape and she
goes
yeah he's a little hit and miss
you jon stewart all of a sudden now he's
hitting him he got downgraded
wow and
she wouldn't know if i was hitting this
she'd never seen me perform but my
jon stewart got
demoted from the funniest thing i've
ever seen to hit and miss
we never watched the tape his name never
was uttered again by her
and it's like
a year or two later he was hosting the
oscars she watches the oscars she never
said a word nothing it was dead she was
dead like i was
at a party with jon stewart just
eight months ago and i just said you
know john
i'm sorry but i lost you a fan
my mom i thought my mom was a huge fan i
can tell
until she found out about us
and she's never uttered your name again
that's great she died never [ __ ] said
yeah they never came up ever again
i mean that's [ __ ] that's not passive
aggressive that's aggressive as [ __ ]
right there yeah my but she she came
she came from my grandmother who was
very kind of aggressive that way
too
and they would they were just [ __ ] up
that way and i don't know why and you
know once in a while my
my grandmother would kind of kid me like
she'd go well you know i got to keep you
grounded which is like first off
you did you did a wonderful job of
grounding me from zero to 30. so
congratulations and two
uh what what would be so wrong if my
gondola
left the ground just a little bit
how many sandbags like you have to keep
me you know i got to keep it real you
know what i mean like kind of thing it's
like
i'm not walking around like m.c hammer
you know in parachute pants i'm just
[ __ ] became successful at something
you don't have to
work hard to keep me grounded
so
i'm still i'm still thinking about not
telling i know right flew by i'm still
thinking about not you haven't told the
kids yet yeah your mom passed so they're
pretty avid listeners of this podcast so
i think are they no i was gonna say
no i don't know what the hell they
listen to they watch friends what are
you when you're gonna wait till they
come to you
i don't know that they'll come to me
right so could it be six months before
you like oh yeah by the way
six years really you'll wait
i'm gonna i've forgotten about it like
like
i i all need to be cued
did you have did you go say goodbye to
your mom like your dad wanted you to
yeah i did but was she in a
uh a state where she really couldn't
hear you or
yeah yeah i think so her health was that
bad at that point she was
yeah at that point she kind of i told
her i loved her i told her i forgave her
and she sort of
you could see your eyes move a little
whatever i forgive you yeah
and then
in
the tradition
of my family
you know at some point
i turned to my
stepdad i went is there any what are the
arrangements yeah i was about to ask you
there's no funeral you guys
nothing no is it cremation or body uh
donated to ucla science science donation
they come get you and that's the end of
us that's it
no events no luncheons no
scatter the ashes over the open sea
so no it's gone
no farewell at all
as much as if if i said to you
i love you and i forgive you and then i
left this podcast studio
whatever happened to you after then that
that's as much
that's wow that's as much as we've done
you will do do you think your kids will
be upset that you didn't tell them or it
really is that far disconnected that
they're like oh i think they'll be more
concerned for you how you're doing
i don't suspect they'll be concerned for
me
and i don't suspect
i my son's a little more sensitive he
may he may have a flash of sensitivity
but i don't think my my daughter's
pretty much gonna be moving on to her
next event
so
now i i know it sounds
exquisitely bizarre and weird but
they just don't have any
connection now what about with your
wife's
uh or their mom's
family
is that a different situation they are
closer to their grandparents on that
side or are they alive they passed sort
of early-ish in their career but they're
close to like nephews and nieces and and
stuff like that so they have some
they understand that they just my side
of the family's just not and you didn't
have any extended no cousins or anything
on that side that you could resonate
with like you believe this [ __ ] these
weirdos and [ __ ] no none of that
no i had i had one like second cousin
and one single child who only child who
lived in uh santa monica who i would you
know we'd hang out look you know a
little bit
but
no there's no no like extended family no
group no
well good for you for breaking the
[ __ ] cycle because you could easily
slide right back into that [ __ ] it's
what you knew from two parents it's not
like you got one that was like that
well i i understood you know
the gift from them is here's what i
don't want you know what i mean like i
don't want to live this way i don't want
to be this way i don't want to raise my
kids this way i don't want to comport
myself this way
i you know you have one broken down car
i want 20 race cars right you know you
have one broken down house that your mom
lets you sleep in i want two houses you
know i i just kind of went whatever it
is you guys are doing i i'm gonna go do
something the other thing the other
thing and that you know
there's a lot to be gleaned from
you know knowing what you don't want to
be you know what i mean i mean
every day just drive down the street and
see some
dude in his all-electric audi
crushing it over there and then see the
homeless dude over there and go all
right i don't want to do that i do want
that all-electric audi
all right so this is this is going to be
an interesting question because i told
you at the beginning when we wrap up we
got to get you out of here advice you
would give to your 16 year old self
after what we've talked about i'm
very interested to hear what you would
say to 16 year old adam carl and knowing
now what your parents were both like
the one thing i needed to hear is that
time passes quickly
and if you stay with what you're
interested in
things have a way of working out you
know all the people i've met in the
business
all the journeys i've seen
they've somehow magically worked out you
know
and
some better than others but they've
basically worked out and
i would just say to the 16 year old adam
first things first you know sports isn't
the future it's going to be comedy
secondly you know just because your
parents never laughed or said write that
down
or encouraged you or heard you or
acknowledged you it doesn't mean you're
not funny
and and it and it doesn't mean other
people won't like you know when i met
jimmy kimmel years and years later he
was like you're [ __ ] funny it's like
there will be people who you meet
who matter who go whoa what is this like
your parents no one in your world your
friends school teachers counselors
you have this thing
it is neither here nor there to all of
them
but it will mean something to other
people later
time will pass quickly and you can get
paid
with this gift that you have
that everyone around you is is saying is
worthless you're basically
you have a
gasoline refinery before cars have been
invented but one day there shall be an
invention called a car
and you will be able to sell your
product yeah that's great advice
dude thank you so much for coming on i
don't i'm sure some of this wasn't easy
to talk about maybe it was you see him
dead to it
it's not easier or hard it just is
um please plug promote anything you'd
like uh you can go to amcurl.com got the
book out now uh called um
everything reminds me something uh you
can go read all my books and 50 years
will all be chicks or president me or
not taco bell material whatever go go
look them up if they don't have a super
high rating on amazon don't buy this
next book but if they do
then buy it
and uh yeah amchur.com live shows travel
around the country but you can listen to
the podcast too
awesome thank you very much man i really
appreciate you doing this
and as always ryan sickler.com ryan
sickler on all social media we'll talk
to you all next week
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you